Brazil is one unhappy country for months
people have been taking to the streets
in protest some of them violent they
want education they want health care
they want housing what they don't want
is the World Cup we don't have a good
schools or that they have good hospitals
people are complaining about the
salaries we have a lot of large problems
that the World Cup is nothing it's a
waste of money and there's lots of money
Brazil is the industrial and
agricultural heart of South America
according to the World Bank GDP per
capita tripled from 2004 to 2012 yet
Brazil still ranks 85th on the UN's
Human Development Index behind Russia
Libya and Venezuela even some of the
cities hosting the World Cup are at best
and bivolo about the event my governor
Dean Manaus did invest our money we're
not given the core of dollar because I
invested in Manaus in the life of my
people I just want the arena you didn't
want the arena no I prefer to reform the
stadium that already existed Manaus is a
jungle city on the banks of the Amazon
San Paulo is a four-hour flight away and
there isn't much civilization in between
yet there are more seats in the arena de
Amazonia than there are in Boston's
Fenway Park once the World Cup is over
this could be a white elephant you have
a lot of needs but
dureena in my opinion must be sold after
the road cup I hope to sell it to some
tuna I try to bring the money back when
I invest don't matter how much money I
must be sure that I have some something
back good socially good economically
would no one expected such
soul-searching when Brazil won the World
Cup rights back in 2007 soccer is like a
religion here this is the country that
produced Pele romário Ronaldo and Neymar
government officials say they're
confident the more than 10 billion
dollars spent preparing for the World
Cup was money well invested
it's parasitic over the moon look at the
hell even Oprah here to help ie after
days you hit one crazy I hear playing
with you inside during four times you
invented this emotional task on on Cuban
ingenuity and if the World Cup doesn't
turn a profit the government is making
sure it serves a social purpose everyday
Brazil plays will be a national holiday
winding the economy to a halt all in the
name of soccer it's a very large loss
they are not expecting to to set upon
during the holidays it's gonna be going
to for the tourists because the people
from this theater they go away will the
World Cup be worth it
Brazil may not know for years